bonjour à tous nous avons le plaisir
d'accueillir maud fontenoy et notre
délégué général en charge de
l'environnement pour faire un petit
point sur la côte 21 tout à l'heure mais
je commence comme d'habitude par notre
point d'agenda sur la semaine avec
aujourd'hui donc ce soir à 19 heures
nicolas sarkozy ira soutenir hervé morin
et françois guégot françoise guégot
pardon à rouen à la halle aux toiles qui
place de la basse vieille tour demain
mardi 1er décembre nous aurons donc le
bureau politique qui se réunira à huis
clos à 18 heures dans cette maison
mercredi 2 décembre
nicolas sarkozy ira soutenir vigier et
guillaume pelletier à orléans
enfin juste à côté d'orléans salle de
montre qu'ils sont avenue jacques
douffiagues à saint-jean-le-blanc et à
19h et bien nous aurons le rendez vous
du projet qui est à l'initiative d'eric
woerth sur le thème de la mer est elle
l'avenir de la terre et ce rendez vous
du projet sera animée par yannick moreau
qui est député de la vendée et
secrétaires nationales à la mer et à la
pêche avec daniel fasquelle député du
pas-de-calais et qui est notre trésorier
ainsi qu alain cadec député européen et
dimanche 6 décembre bien nous on dans
cette maison la soirée électorale du
premier tour des élections régionales et
vous y êtes cordialement invités alors
hier place de la république
cette place qui a été qui est l'hôtel
des victimes des attentats de janvier
mais également de novembre
a été le théâtre de manifestants de
manifestations scandaleuse qui ont
débordé et des manies ces manifestants
se sont pris aux forces de l'ordre
ces scènes sont intolérables et nous les
condamnons avec la plus grande fermeté
et nous appelons à ce qu'elle à ce que
ces manifestants soit condamné avec la
plus grande sévérité
nous pensons aux victimes des attentats
de novembre mais également à leur
famille puisque les bougies de l'hôtel
dédiés aux victimes ont été utilisées
contre les forces de l'ordre et le est
le symbole et est plus que que
détestable et c'est une grande grande
tristesse
rappelons tout de même que l'état
d'urgence a été décrété et n'est pas on
peut le constater n'est absolument pas
respectée
cela démontre qui est un véritable
problème d'autorité
malgré cet état d'urgence l'autorité de
la république l'autorité du gouvernement
n'est absolument pas respectée il est
bafouée comme il l'était avant les
attentats
il est bafouée encore aujourd'hui à
cause de ces de ces manifestations qui
ont qui ont été débordées et nous
soutenons nous devrions dire un mot pour
les forces de l'ordre qui ont quand même
été victime de ces de ces affrontements
assez violent et leur dire également
notre soutien notre respect et et que
nous sommes évidemment de de leur côté
car car ils ont toujours été là lorsque
lorsque la france et ses enfants ont été
attaqués jeu maintenant à céder la
parole à mode qui va faire un point sur
sur la coop 21 bonjour à tous alors
c'est mon premier point-presse pardonnez
moi donc sur la coque j'imagine que tout
le monde ici est bien conscient des
différents enjeux sur l'urgence à mettre
d'accord tous ces pays du monde sur la
difficulté de les mettre d'accord
puisqu'il faut un accord qui soit signé
à l'unanimité sur
l'état de ce réchauffement qui va
grandissant et qu'il va falloir qu'on
limite à 2 degrés d'ici la fin du siècle
est en rapport à l'ère préindustrielle
et notre volonté nous républicain déjà
de souhaiter bonne chance à la france
puisque la france a est quand même le
pays hôte et et joue un rôle lui
souhaiter bonne chance et en même temps
espéré
un accord contraignant pourquoi un
accord contraignant parce que les bonnes
intentions des uns et des autres ne
suffiront plus aujourd'hui au vu des
échéances donc il faut un accord qui
soit contraignant donc un traité qui
soit comme celui de kyoto en 97 qui
puisse inclure deux dans un aspect de
suivi est derrière ce suivi des
engagements évidemment un aspect de
contraintes
il va falloir mobiliser les états sur
toutes les questions d'énergie et
notamment d'énergie fossile que faisons
nous est-ce qu'on limite est ce qu on
n'imite pas il faut que ça soit mis dans
l'accord et puis évidemment parler du
fond vert se font vers les financements
comment est-ce qu'on finance
l'accès à l'énergie à ces pays en
développement il suffit pas nous la
france que l'on que l'on donne des
leçons mais qu'on propose des solutions
à ces pays pour qui l'accès à l'énergie
aujourd'hui et demain puisque ce
réchauffement on en parle c'est surtout
pour demain et parce qu'on fait une
projection de notre consommation
d'énergie d'aujourd'hui notre projection
fait que ça va se réchauffer mais
aujourd'hui si on en restait à l'heure
actuelle ça irait mais c'est cette
projection qui est compliqué et dont il
faut bien envisager cette projection sur
les pays en développement qui auront
forcément accès à cette énergie parce
que c'est l'accès à l'emploi l'accès à
l'éducation l'accès à la santé l'accès à
la survie et qui va bien falloir leur
proposer des solutions clés en main et
que tout ça va avoir un coût rappeler
que même si on attendait beaucoup de
copenhague copenhague est quand même
servi à mettre sur pied le fonds vers ce
fameux fonds vert dont on attend
beaucoup ici à paris c'est ensuite après
copenhague que l'on a décidé de mettre
un aspect qu'on craignant notamment
ensuite en afrique du sud en 2011 dans
dans l'accord donc c'est une long
processus qui a été aujourd'hui met en
oeuvre et que l'on espère aboutir cette
année peut-être un point sur la france
sur le fait que la france aujourd'hui ne
faut pas le nier est exemplaire en terme
environnemental
pourquoi parce que le réchauffement est
dû aux émissions de gaz à effet de serre
des émissions de gaz à effet de serre
sont dus principalement l'énergie
aujourd'hui la france le français chacun
d'entre nous va émettre environ 6 tonnes
de co2 par personne par an environ la
même quantité qu'un chinois peu près
pareil entre 6 et 7
pourquoi parce que la france est
exemplaire grâce à son nucléaire
et pourquoi est-ce qu'on stigmatise la
chine parce qu'ils sont très très
nombreux
ensuite ce chiffre est bon notamment par
rapport à nos amis allemands pour qui
les deux environ neuf donc beaucoup plus
du fait du charbon et les américains qui
évidemment dépasse les 16 voire 17
tonnes de co2 par personne par an donc
aujourd'hui il faut se féliciter de
cette politique énergétique française du
fait de son nucléaire et on trouve ici
aux républicains assez incohérent de
vouloir par le même temps être
exemplaire donner des leçons au monde
entier et souhaitait diminuer notre part
du nucléaire
c'est à dire aller à l inverse de ce que
l'on dit en réalité est d'être dans une
posture dans un certain dogmatisme qui
n'est pas du tout pragmatique c'est à
dire que fermer fessenheim
au-delà des 4 milliards que ça coûtera à
l'économie française et on cherche de
l'argent aujourd'hui fessenheim il fait
un bénéfice net par an de 350 millions
d'euros 350 millions d'euros par an
c'est de l'argent qu'il faut
impérativement qu'on investisse dans le
renouvelable et dans les techniques de
stockage pour pallier à l'intermittence
des énergies propres a donc fermer
fessenheim c'est une hérésie
face aux grands enjeux qui sont ceux de
la coop 21
donc on aimerait bien un peu une
cohérence de discours je pense
aujourd'hui fondamental de porter une
écologie qui soit cohérente modéré et
pragmatique réaliste réalisable et
que sombrer dans l'utopisme en étant
contre tous et pas forcément le message
que souhaite faire passer aux français
pas plus qu'au monde est juste un
dernier point par rapport aux élections
régionales personnellement
l'environnement est fondamentale pour
moi les enjeux de cette conférence au
climat sont primordiaux pour l'avenir du
vivre ensemble sur ces questions
énergétiques et il est dommageable que
ces élections régionales qui devait
avoir lieu en mars dernier ont été
finalement repoussée à cette période de
l'année qui finalement va probablement
faire un mélange et qui n'est pas bon je
pense pour les thématiques
environnementales
merci merci moi donc nous avons eu la
semaine dernière un chiffre qui est
passée un peu sous silence le
gouvernement a été aux abonnés absents
d'ailleurs sur ce sujet c'est le chiffre
du chômage puisque nous avons découvert
que nous avions eu au mois d'octobre la
plus forte augmentation du chômage
depuis depuis trois ans avec + 42 mille
demandeurs d'emploi en catégorie 1 en
catégorie à part dont on s'aperçoit que
donc mois après mois que l'inversion de
la courbe du chômage n'est vraiment pas
au rendez vous le gouvernement s'était
gargariser sur le chiffre du mois de
septembre qui était en diminution et
aujourd'hui on s'aperçoit que il a été
particulièrement aux abonnés absents sur
le chiffres catastrophiques du mois
d'octobre s'aperçoit aussi que sur les
28 pays de l'union
23 pays voient leur chômage diminue et
un pays voit le chiffre de son chômage
stagner et quatre pays dont la france
voit le nombre de ses chômeurs augmente
et sachant que la france est le pays qui
voit son chômage le plus augmenté de
l'ensemble de ces quatre pays
donc dans le cadre il ya un vrai lien
avec d'ailleurs la campagne des
élections régionales puisque vous avez
les régions ont une grosse compétences
en matière économique et en matière de
formation et c'est une thématique
primordial pour l'ensemble de nos
candidats aux élections régionales de
remettre la france au travail il y
aurait le slogan le landau candidats en
nord pas de calais picardie et xavier
bertrand l'a notre région au travail
mais l'ensemble des candidats
républicains mettent l'accent sur les
thématiques d'emploi donc viala la
compétence économique mais via aussi la
compétence d'apprentissage et de
formation professionnelle donc il faut
que les français des électeurs regardent
avec attention cette partie des
programmes régionaux pour permettre
enfin de combattre ce fléau qui est le
chômage et on s'aperçoit par exemple que
depuis 2012 en allemagne la baisse du
chômage est de 20% alors que en france
l'augmentation du chômage est de + 29 %
c'est c'est finalement la politique
économique et fiscale du gouvernement
politique qui est désastreuse qui qui
amène à voir ses résultats depuis plus
de trois ans maintenant on va on va
passer à la question de la turquie les
républicains sont favorables à l'aide
accordée de 3 milliards d'euros à la
turquie cette aide permettra à la
turquie de mieux accueillir et de fixer
la population donc des migrants sur son
territoire avec cette partie de l'accord
qu'ils doivent respecter notamment sur
la scolarisation des enfants des
migrants la lutte contre les trafiquants
qui sont les passeurs qui qui mettent en
danger la vie
c'est nombreuses familles et puis un
contrôle de leurs frontières
en revanche nous nous tirons la sonnette
d'alarmé car nous refusons cette espèce
de chantage qui consiste à profiter de
la crise des migrants pour pourrait
ouvrir la négociation sur l'adhésion de
la turquie à l'europe ce n'est pas
responsable de laisser penser aux turcs
que l'on va engager à nouveau ces
négociations que l'on va à nouveau
réouvrir le processus de négociations
sur une éventuelle adhésion de la
turquie à l'europe
de toute façon soyons pragmatiques 90%
du territoire turc se trouve en asie
donc donc pour ces raisons là et puis
pour d'autres raisons
notre position chez les républicains n'a
absolument pas évolué nous ne sommes pas
favorables à une adhésion de la turquie
en europe mais nous sommes véritablement
engagé pour aider la turquie à mieux
accueillir les populations est favorable
à cette aide de trois milliards qui a
été qui a été décidé finalement notre
position est simple nous sommes opposés
à l'adhésion de la turquie et l'union
européenne
et il ya trois raisons finalement
géographiquement historiquement et
culturellement la turquie ne fait pas
partie de l'europe